this is Afghanistan's first under the
Taliban in more than 20 years
it also comes at a time of international
sanctions and a struggling economy with
millions of Avalons out of work are
being paid a fraction of what they once
were many are cutting back on their
holiday expenses
Muhammad Nabi a dried fruit seller in
kabul's largest open-air market says
with local currency losing its value
prices have gone up so people are buying
fewer items he says dried fruit sellers
have lost 60 to 70 percent of their
business this year
people are poor nowadays we don't have
enough sales this year pistachios alone
went from 600 afghanis to more than one
thousand a kilos
foreign it's not just snacks though
families are also opting out of buying
new clothes for the holiday
a tailor in the Corte Parowan
neighborhood says his orders have
decreased 50 percent this year
we have only these two celebrations the
two eats traditionally whatever people
have they will spend on these two eats
but this year A lot of people are
struggling
some are even cutting back on the most
important part of this eat purchasing
animals for the ritual sacrifice
has a job in a Ministry but he says his
pay has been cut by more than 80 percent
he has managed to buy a cow and a sheep
for his family but he knows many more
will not be able to do the same this
year
is made special by the sacrifice so many
people won't have a proper sense of
celebrating Eid
popal says this year more than ever it's
important to keep the poor in mind
this Market is the centerpiece of the
idolata celebration but what we've seen
this year is that people can't afford to
buy the animals that they used to and
the Shepherds have also had to cut their
prices to meet reduced demand so again
what it's showing is that the sanctions
the aid cutbacks and the devaluation of
the avani has affected every aspect of
life in Afghanistan right down to the
Eid celebration
Ali latifi Al Jazeera Kabul